[Music]  new Vols would give posted workers in  the EU the same pay as local workers MEP  is looking to the compromise agreed with  Member States the Parliament hosts a  high-level conference on the EU and the  digital economies opportunities and  challenges looking at how to foster  innovation protect EU citizens and  benefit business accessible culture is  one of the --use top priorities MEP s  will discuss the financial educational  and structural barriers to access and  how best to combat them how do you know  that your second-hand car really has  done the mileage that it says it hurts  Parliament puts forward proposals on how  to tackle mileage fraud the Parliament  votes are new rules to simplify a silo  procedure the EU wants to discourage  migrants from applying for asylum in  more than one state  you